[Music]
if there's ever been a time for big
ideas this
is it we're a nation long on talent and
ambition but are too many regions short
on opportunity and leadership towns and
the businesses in those localities are
best able to identify the skills they
need how can businesses build back green
and how can new companies challenge them
we rely on the land so we don't exist
unless we we show respect what secure
work will be created once the pandemic
has been and gone and i will say it
really is fragile we're on the knife
edge it's time for big ideas live
[Music]
welcome to the face of steel here at the
magna science adventure center in the
former temple steel works in rotherham
we're here for big ideas live a new
format for sky news that we hope will
help us to explore big issues big themes
big ideas across the agenda for the uk
today
somebody who knows the uk economy better
than pretty much anybody else he also
happens to be the man who's galvanizing
the financial sector uh ahead of that
big push towards net zero at cop26 so
i'm going to introduce you now to dr
mark carney mark really good to see you
this morning i appreciate you getting up
super early at canadian time to speak to
us
i wanted to start by talking to you mark
if i may about cop 26 just over two
weeks to go i know you've been working
very hard towards it
prince charles says there's a chance it
could just be all talk how confident are
you that we'll see some action at that
conference
well first it's great to see you sam and
thanks for having me uh
we are seeing action uh we need to see
more but we are seeing big action and as
you know i'm concentrating on the
private financial sector so city of
london but really the global financial
sector and there's two big things we
need to do for cop the first is to
change the i'll use a metaphor the
plumbing of the system so the
information the tools create some new
markets there's 24 very wonky detailed
things that needed to be done for cobb
they're all going to be completed for
glasgow so that's the first thing and
that what that does is it reorients the
system to
providing capital to move towards net
zero or where our economy needs to go
where the world needs to go the second
big thing we need to do is to get a very
large amount of money
that is going to be lent and invested
towards that net zero to help drive our
economy forward but also help get
emissions down and as we meet today uh
the number of banks insurers uh big
pension funds around the world who've
committed to that
that number 18 months ago was five
trillion dollars five trillion today
it's over 90 trillion nine zero trillion
dollars and so there's been an enormous
shift in that uh in the run-up to
clockwork continuing to build that uh
momentum into cops so that we have
enough money
that's needed for the investment to make
the transition so i think we're seeing
more a lot more than talk
and mark i know you're advising the
prime minister um the uk clearly needs
to set an example here we're hosting the
conference
um its own independent committee has
been critical of the uk government's
lack of plan
are you aware of a detailed uk
government plan to get us to net zero
well the first thing to say and i have
the opportunity to see approaches around
the world given my role and the uk's
overall approach is absolutely the right
one in the following respects one it has
a very clear objective secondly it has
as you say an independent committee
which assesses how good our policies are
relative to that objective and what that
committee the climate change committee
is saying is that there's a gap between
what we're saying is our objective and
where the policies are
and it's identifying the size of that
gap now that's okay in the sense of
there are always other budgets there's
always additional plans and there's
additional things being put in place and
the uk has been stepping up whether it's
on wind whether it's on the moratorium
on internal combustion engines
whether it's on hydrogen the hydrogen
economy yes more needs to be done but we
have a much better idea in the uk
where the gap is between ambition and
action
and governments can put forward i would
stress it again as well that the uk
financial system and that's not just our
banks but very much our insurers and
pension funds have moved hugely and in
many respects are leading this and this
can help pull forward uh the adjustment
uh that the governments need to make but
government climate policy needs to be
credible doesn't it mark is it helpful
that there is an inquiry as to whether
we should be uh building a new coal
mining cumbria and doing oil and gas
exploration up in scotland
yeah well i think uh let me let me put
it this way i think it is helpful that
an inquiry is being done into this and
independent inquiry is being done to
this because it shows exactly what the
issues are around the transition uh
let's take the example of the uh of the
coal uh mine in cumbria which is coal
being used for steel not coal being used
for power generation but still has an
environmental impact if it's done uh
there is a gap between um the life of
that coal mine it could run until 2050
effectively uh the life of that coal
mine and what
our trajectory needs to be in the uk in
order to get to net zero a coal mine
like that really can only run in the
judgment of that independent panel until
2035. let's talk about the climate
finance then um
falling short of what was pledged in
copenhagen 100 billion dollars a year
for developing nations is it the united
states that's holding things up because
they seem to have the biggest
bridge to build here
yeah so the first thing to say is for
anyone coming to this new or not
following a day-to-day the numbers are
absolutely enormous so
what you're asking about is as you know
100 billion dollars a year this was a
pledge of
the rich countries basically to help the
poorer countries developing economies
with the transition it was made 10 years
ago in copenhagen and we haven't met it
yet and it's one of the key objectives
for the uk for this for glasgow for cop
is to get to that number now two weeks
ago there was the meeting of the un
general assembly prime minister was
there um and uh actually the u.s stepped
up they doubled their commitment to over
11 billion i think it's 11.4 billion uh
dollars um there are a number of other
countries who are looking to potentially
add to theirs uh canada and germany are
managing a process not me personally but
others uh managing a process to get to
that 100 billion number it's very
important but at the same time and i
apologize to your audience
just to put in context we need to
multiply that by a thousand
uh in terms of additional
capital additional finance in other
words we need not just a hundred billion
dollars we need a hundred trillion
dollars over the next uh two decades two
and a half decades in order to get to
where we need to go and the point that
we've recognized very early on is that's
only going to come from the private
sector which is why there's been such a
focus on the things i was talking about
at the start which is to get the private
sector aligned uh to move money towards
uh companies and projects that are
solutions to this problem yeah
while we've got you mark we're running
out of time i do want to ask you about
the uk economy quite a few spasms in it
at the moment we've got all the coveted
scarring of course cost of living crisis
energy crisis as well what's your take
well uh the uk is going through as as
others are but maybe a little more
sharply the uk is going through a series
of
uh
supply shocks to use the economic term
we have the adjustment from covet and
acceleration of changes in business
whether it's on the digital side perhaps
most prominently
we have the big move in energy prices uh
which which we're seeing elsewhere but
more so in the uk which brings its own
impact
we have the aftermath of brexit and the
readjustment of the economy that comes
so we have all three of those factors
coming together um and it's uh it it
means by and and we have the beginnings
of this net zero transition we're really
at the early stages of it uh and it
means that um uh there there are there
are some frictions in the economies and
and and adjustments that are necessary
can i ask you as well i can't resist
really i mean the supply chain ruptures
labor shortages disputes over the good
friday agreement
do you feel like one of those derided
experts who was opining on these things
in the run-up to the referendum back in
2016 who now feels a bit like i told you
so
no no absolutely i mean i i our job the
bank of england's job and the run-up uh
to both the referendum but very much to
brexit itself was to make sure the
financial system was in a position to be
part of the solution i think what we
have seen
is that the financial system uk
financial system has stood up as a
through this period including of
disruption and what at least i'm doing
and working with others including the
bank of england the treasury uh more
broadly is making sure the financial
system is ready and part of the solution
for climate change so moving on to the
next big thing
and and and that's what we can do of
course part of making sure that it was
ready was to look at what could go wrong
in the types of supply chains and
uh inflationary and other impacts that
could come
from the the adjustment the initial
phase of adjustment and i i think what
people can
look it may be cold comfort to some
extent but uh you know be reassured that
the uk financial system is very strong
uh and uh it's part of the solution both
in the short term um and what we're
doing for glasgow is making sure that it
is part of the solution uh for this
transition towards net zero and the last
point if i may and that is the
transition that will i saw it at graphs
earlier that will continue to grow this
economy uh
at a speed that people expect in paris
the notable achievement was to get
countries to dare to imagine that
maximum temperature increase of of one
and a half degrees what do you think
could be the headline from glasgow
i think absolutely we've got to keep one
and a half degrees alive so imagination
is one thing and vision is one thing but
action is what's needed
so we have a few more weeks
we will do everything we can on the
financial sector to ensure that there's
real action and commitment so that the
money is there
what's clear is that the money is there
for the transition that's one core plank
we need for glasgow the second is that
countries step up uh not just with
ambition but with policy that uh meets
that ambition
[Music]
let me just show you my kind of big
ideas and hopefully all of that will
actually kind of
kind of ring a bell when it comes to to
what you're going through at the moment
we do a lot of talking both in sky news
in the world of economics about these
things lines lines that show you whether
gdp is going up you saw one a moment ago
lines that show you whether inflation is
going up lines that show you whether
people are getting richer
but i think
this is by the way is by a guy called
john playfair it's one of the earliest
examples of charts
and i love it it's so it's they're so
beautiful
but we need to do
a bit less of that
and a bit more of this
we don't talk about maps enough when it
comes to economics
and what do i mean by maps we need
better maps what do i mean by maps here
well think about
what we might be facing here see it's
not the kind of map you were expecting
was it
um
the threat of a potential bacon shortage
uh in the uk
um
what is the map behind that well there
is a kind of chain reaction isn't there
that's led to this
potential bacon shortage partly there's
the kind of labor thing we talked about
a moment ago when it comes to kind of
getting enough people to work work
within agriculture but partly it's also
this a co2 shortage so not enough co2
and why do we have not enough co2 it's
because fertilizer plants shut down and
why do fertilizers shut down it's
because of record energy prices and why
do we have record energy prices well
it's because of a whole range of factors
you know not as much gas coming from
russia you have problems with uh with
the amount of gas that we're storing
here but also on top of that on the
other side of the world in china you've
got coal mines being shut down and some
of them being flooded recently
so when i talk about maps what i mean is
this kind of unexpected cascade this
chain reaction a chaos effect
where a butterfly wings flaps on one
side of the world and then suddenly
you're out of bacon on the other side of
the world
coal mines shut down chain reaction all
the way through we don't understand that
stuff very well and i you know certainly
within the world of economics but the
reason that i think it's you know quite
significant that we here talking to you
is that we want to try and understand it
better
and i think it's businesses around the
country
that work within these supply chains
that understand this stuff more
intimately certainly more intimately
than the government for whom this came
as an enormous surprise and more
intimately than most of us let me give
you one other example of another kind of
chain reaction
same thing again chinese coal mine
shutdowns
why is that going to have an impact on
semiconductors
because no one really when people talk
about semiconductor shortage they're not
talking about coal mining but they
should
let me show you why
if you want semiconductors if you want
to make computer chips
you need silicone metal if you want
silicon metal you need coking coal
a lot of coking coal goes into the
production of silicone metal i need
silicon metal
to make polysilicon polysilicon to make
silicon wafers and silicon wafers to
make semiconductors
this
supply chain
is not very widely understood
and yet it's incredibly important for
the way the world fits together and we
need better maps of this kind of thing
and this is what i'm talking about i'm
going to show you one more chart and
then we're going to talk to um torsten
bell who's uh who's been watching this
probably with dismay about the idea of
having to discuss all this random stuff
but
chinese culture mine shutdowns silicon
metal this is all coming our way in
terms of semiconductor shortage right
now the shortage that we have is largely
happening within places like taiwan it's
in fabs that basically aren't able to
produce enough to kind of keep the
automobile sector uh supplied
but this side of things we don't talk
about enough but let me show you what's
happening to silicon metal prices so
that metal that you need coal for it's
been more or less flat for most of
recent history this goes all the way
back to 2016. but just recently
except earlier on september there was a
production cut of silicon metal in
yunnan province in china where a lot of
this stuff is produced just look at what
happened to the silicon metal price
and that's something that's very rarely
remarked on it's something where people
aren't really putting those pieces
together
and trying to understand how that is
about to come down the road to us
but when we talk about inflation when we
talk about the state of the economy this
is the kind of thing
that we should be discussing
i want to bring in torsten bell from the
resolution foundation
who should be down the line
from
westminster who i hope has been
listening to some of that
and i uh probably with with with some uh
trepidation uh i want to start ashley
thorsten by asking you about
that question of the labor market the
question of you know whether we do have
a kind of low-wage low-skill economy
and kind of where we are on that
particular uh path
well i mean i think there's some there's
obviously some good news in that space
ed which is you know what we learned
over the last
what have we lost over the last 20 years
is that yes we have been a country
with more
low paid hourly low paid people than
most similar countries
but actually having now decided to
introduce a minimum wage at the end of
the last century and then to
aggressively ramp it up under this
government over the last
five years we've actually seen a very
big fall the first fall in low pay for
four decades and it happened without big
losses in employment so we've learned
that the country had a problem and that
policy was able to make a very big
difference to that and that you know
these are not small fry amounts of money
for people you know even just looking at
the rise since 2016 a full-time minimum
wage worker will be well over a thousand
pounds a year better off because of that
policy change
[Music]
can the identity and pride felt by many
communities
across the north of england helped to
drive economic growth
simone is there an opportunity for the
north in this crisis um i think we're
always going to look at an opportunity
when we set out
at the start of the pandemic is what can
we do and i think our focus has always
been about what can we do we know
there's lots of barriers there we know
there's lots of inequality we know
there's lots of hurdles but from the
campaign and the movement that i created
which is about accelerating gender
equality and social mobility from the
north it's very much looking about that
we can approach and so at the start of
the pandemic like what can we do what
can we do the first thing was to check
in on people was to check in how are we
going to wrap an arm around these senior
business leaders doing amazing you know
making these you know um
history making uh decisions every day
and also to checking on those at the
start of their career who think actually
what an earth is ahead of me i don't
want anybody to to leave this thinking
that the north is just a place where
everybody is exactly the same i suspect
that there are people who think that
there are
imbalances here alison matthews i think
has a point on this in relation to uh
transport allison
i feel like durham and newcastle really
get forgotten about and it's not just
when it comes to transport it's a lot of
things when you talk about the north
when government talk about the north
tends to be manchester liverpool leeds
and the north east really does get
forgotten about are we going to get
included in things
there is a really crucial identity
question we mentioned the north east
here and you know there is a north of
time melody at the moment which to me is
completely mad when there is a clear
economic unit in tyneside that includes
newcastle gatesair dumpster and what
have you you could create conurbation
around that why does that not exist
because all the local council leaders
were arguing and they wouldn't do a deal
with each other so sometimes problems of
these things are founded locally due to
local rivals due to people's feelings
about each other if you don't mind me
trevor you'll come back on the point
that was made earlier about
business investment i think that is
actually very key here because yes you
can pull money into transport yes you
can make up for decades of under
investment but to get a sustainable
economy in the places that have
struggled you've got to make an
appetizing business environments and i
think there's obviously the government
are looking at free ports you've got
questions about enterprise zones things
you do to encourage business investments
so when that white paper comes out later
this month that's actually what i'm most
interested in because it's easy to pour
money into things but you can only do
that so many times and that doesn't
create a sustainable economic base when
you hit the next downturn and public
spending eventually gets cut back and if
you look at the example of liverpool
when it was regenerated um in the 1980s
and 1990s that was based on public
private partnerships i think that has to
be really key to this if you're going to
make it not just a one-off hit there is
a labor market problem isn't there that
we aren't necessarily
uh we don't necessarily have
the right
people with the right skills in the
right place one thing is clear the
regions the cities the towns and the
businesses in those localities are best
able to identify the skills they need
they're also able to identify the
matching of skills to jobs whether it's
high skills and low skills i think
there's something to be said about
giving
a kind of real autonomy to the regions
to decide what they want for their
businesses for the individuals for the
regions and the cities but i think
there's complication around
managing the wider concept
administratively and logistically
um
the issue of immigration and we need to
handle that with care
empowerment but i think there's also got
to be that cross-regional collaboration
as well because otherwise you're
reinvented wheels so i think it's the
power in that coming together
um
we've heard mentioned several times in
this discussion the leveling up white
paper uh for which
you know there are millions sitting
waiting uh rather like you know waiting
for the new harry potter or whatever it
is um
i'm going to ask each one of you to tell
me
something that you really want to see in
that white paper
you know whether it is a number
of money or it is a sentence or it is a
policy hesseltine saying
you know uh have accountable leaders in
every place and that would be the thing
that made difference so each one of you
start with you chris
if you if if the prime minister rang up
and said chris you've got a paragraph
and
you can write it and nobody can
interfere with it what would it be
what i would have is a commitment to
nuclear energy we need reliable
cheap energy the northwest of england
has a huge nuclear sector huge amounts
of talent in northwest of england so i
want to see that because i believe the
north of england and parliament leveling
a significant part of our leveling up
ought to be manufacturing including
heavy manufacturing
and therefore we need reliable energy
that doesn't go out every time uh the
wind stops blowing so nuclear energy
it's good for industry and it's going to
be good for the north
our west people investment in uh
ensuring that they we can
trump all form of fear that young people
have right now about what their future
is and makes that they can thrive and
grow their career in the north and seats
at the table for
female female lab businesses black asian
minority led businesses and young people
when these big decisions are being made
and a i can give you the bank details
for a bank account for that to be paid
into
[Laughter]
yeah well um
you can find that on the website okay
charles trevor you'll expect me to say
real investment in skills and jobs and
in the potential of the young ones and i
think the university sector the higher
education sector and the further
education sector really really play a
role in trying to build this skilled
base that the smes and large
organizations need
research and development there needs to
be funding in that and i think they need
to be funding in the relationship
between businesses and the academic
sector so
i want to see a very clear plan of
delivery about how all these changes are
going to be made because it's so easy
for politicians to talk about improving
life chances improving town centers
improving infrastructure but what we are
talking about is hundreds if not
thousands of tiny projects all across
the country which on the whole will
level up and i think essentially you
need to see a way to actually do that
because for me to successfully level up
is as big of a challenge to the british
state as brexit and we know that took a
long time and a lot of effort so i want
clear detail plan and accountability
data metrics what does success look like
[Music]
is boris johnson's promise of a high
wage high skills economy deliverable and
what would it mean for business and all
the problems that we're seeing in the
country's supply chains a symptom of
short-term worker shortages or are we in
for a longer ride i'll be discussing
that with a panel
lord billy mora i'm going to start with
you we heard from boris johnson last
week he clearly wants to turn the uk
into a high wage economy but it seems to
me i mean economic orthodoxy is that
high wages follow an improvement in
productivity boris johnson it feels like
he's trying to put the car before the
horse
we all want uh
a high
wage
high skills
high investment
and high productivity
so you can say you want high wages but
unless you have all the other things
it's going to lead to inflation
so we've got to take this opportunity
now
we all want those higher wages but
invest in skills how important is it for
young people to have a voice in the
dialogue around the future of work i
think yeah you're very well placed
brilliant question absolutely integral
for young people to be part of that
dialogue what we know is we have
one of the most diverse most educated
labour coming through young people
coming through into the economy and
they're very clear about what they want
they're very clear you know they are
mobile they're resilient they're values
driven they want businesses that are
supporting their well-being they want
ethical leadership and i think they have
to be part of the solution but for me
the onus really is on
the employers
you know to be able to change their
culture change their practices change
their
recruitment and hiring
practices in order to attract this
phenomenal talent that is in the uk i
think that we can all agree that
education and health should be
considered as important as our finance
sectors and and we we shouldn't really
accept lower salaries in this areas as a
result of that so surely recruitment
retention and quality could all be
improved as a result of increased
investment in these areas but not just
from a training and pre-employment
perspective but following on we need to
keep people in these jobs and then
ultimately they act as role models for
the young people coming through i think
you're absolutely spot on that
lifelong learning is incredibly
important now it's not just about
entry level it's throughout because we
know the labor force that's coming
through is much more mobile if we're not
going to give them the experience if
we're not going to look after them we're
not going to
ensure that their well-being is priority
then they will leave and we'll be you
know the investment is gone
um but the point you're making around
role models is absolutely important um
relatable people who can support young
people in places like rotherham you know
where there is generations of
worklessness
and say to them look we made it you can
make it this is the way we will support
you and invest and tell those young
people that you are important
is beyo i think that's a single thing
that will
um address some of the complexities in
our labour market mentoring is key we've
got a budget coming up on the 27th of
this month we've had the institute for
fiscal studies yesterday their green
budget and they're making the point that
essentially spending on the nhs is
crowding out all other areas of public
spending those unprotected areas of
government local government education
defense transport all of those are going
to be squeezed all the money is going to
the nhs are you comfortable with the way
that the nhs almost appears to be a
cuckoo in the nest and that all other
public spending has been crowded out
historically if you look at overall
public spending to gdp
we've tried to get to around 40 percent
of of gdp
now if you look at the figures during
the pandemic i mean it's gone way over
that then you say that's in a time of
crisis then you say you need more
spending on health which we do then you
say you need more one of the things a
pandemic has really highlighted is
social care that it's been a neglected
sector how do we now looking forward
give the spending is required but also
increase the tax take to be able to
spend to spend it to pay for it but also
increase the growth
because if you have a an austerity
high tax
that will stifle growth that will stifle
domestic investment that will stifle
inward investment with the second
largest recipient of inward investment
in the world if you put up taxes too
much if you're if your spending is out
of kill you will not attract that
investment clive have you run the
numbers how much is this rise in
national insurance next year going to
cost you
painful
pain but it's not but it's it's not just
national insurance it's it's the cost
increases we're seeing on virtually
every line of the p l so it's the
cumulative impact of that but in terms
of the government investment and where
the money goes i would encourage the
government to think of it as investment
and not as a cost so particularly
you know
obviously you know my world is embedded
in pubs and hospitality we it by
supporting our sector
that is supporting the regeneration of
jobs and local economies in
in hundreds of thousands of every town
and village actually across the uk we
are the you know we are a good conduit
to reinvesting in local communities
creating jobs investing capital into
uh into our buildings into new
businesses
and investing in in improving our
businesses and we're still at that stage
at this transition stage where you know
we need that support to be able to help
to stimulate the government uh the
economy recovery and the leveling up
agenda carl you must be seeing that as
well absolutely i mean the the cost
increases have have been uh so you know
quite quite brutal for for all for all
sectors i think it is a difficult
challenges for the government as to
whether spend the money i always think
of it as they've they've got to spend it
where they think they're going to get
the best value from it it's prosperity
throughout all the regions
and it should not be at the expense of
london it should be london prospering
benefits the whole country but it's
london and the rest of the country
and when it comes to climate change
heat is such a big issue that we we
don't address i chaired the heat
commission one third of greenhouse gas
emissions comes from heat
half of that comes from buildings and
out of the 29 homes in this country 29
million homes in this country only 1
million are up to the standard if we're
to reach net zero by 2050 that means
upgrading 28 million homes the cost of
that the jobs that are created to scale
and implement that
the body that needs to be created we've
got the national center for
decarbonization of heat in the west
midlands that could do this throughout
the country it's a huge challenge and
we've got to face it we've got cop26 the
un climate change conference this is
where britain can show global leadership
on the stage well we're all about big
ideas and i think you've just come up
with a big idea for jobs there
and if i can just add
what gives me confidence that how we'll
get there and how it will be funded
i have no idea but what i do know is
that is that i have absolute confidence
and excitement about the younger age
group our consumer of tomorrow or today
will demand these things so they won't
be coming into our pubs if they don't
meet you know the the the criteria and
you know
and that actually gives me the
confidence uh from an employee workforce
point of view they want to work for us
our consumers won't want to be coming in
so these changes absolutely um will come
through we have to find a way of funding
them effectively
[Music]
as the world comes out of the pandemic
we need to be thinking about how
businesses build back green and also how
they build back their balance sheets as
well and the inevitable tensions between
those two uh we'll be talking about what
the government can be doing what it is
doing what it should be doing all of
that i'll be discussing all of that with
my panel who kindly assembled here for
us
i want to start by
asking you what your perception of the
uk economy is i mean it feels a bit like
it's at a fulcrum moment as hopefully we
emerge from from the pandemic we have
green issues very pressing so we're a
food business
and of course like other food businesses
have been navigating the pandemic making
sure that food flows to consumers
and
there's been a number of disruptions all
the way through i guess the disruptions
that we're working with at the moment is
a shortage of labor particularly driver
labour
that's an industry-wide problem
and just simply being able to get the
product from our factories to
supermarkets is a real challenge in
terms of investing in the various
aspects of your business and do you have
the confidence to be doing that at the
moment because the economy economy it
feels like it could go any which way
doesn't it we're a farmer-owned business
so our farmers actually own us and an
investment is something that we're very
used to doing over a very long period of
time and therefore
we have continued to do that in all of
our operations so
our farmers uh you know
are very keen to stay in farming you
know for generations and therefore the
investments that they make and not just
short-term capital investments but
with the idea that the next generation
will have a farm that's in a better
state than they uh they inherited
themselves so we're a purpose-driven
startup and we focus on the global
maritime industry
and so
in 2018 and 2019 we invented a wing sale
um
and went through a feasibility process
with academics
demonstrated that we could save 20 fuel
and emissions from
huge ships by retrofitting this
technology and we're on a roll and it's
going great and everybody's really
enthusiastic about it i feel like
there's a butt coming that's about
coming covered comes and so the so it
really takes the wind out of our sails
you know the moment literally the
momentum goes
um
everybody's focusing now on how do we
deal with this pandemic how do we deal
with this crisis and so having a startup
to come along and knock on your door and
say oh by the way would you like to have
that conversation we were having it no
we don't because we're focusing on very
survival
so
what the impact of that is so so i the
way that i see this
covid crisis is that it's a kind of
there's a word that i've heard
shudderation is that what's what it
feels like the economy has just come to
a kind of shuddering
halt it's still moving forward but is
this an opportunity for us to start to
rethink how we build it for the future
and what do you think what's your
initial thought my thought is we have no
option i mean the climate crisis is so
great that it makes covid seem like you
know something that we we managed quite
well and i think we've got a lot of
lessons to learn from how we manage
covid
and we can we can do the same with the
climate crisis vicky i want to bring you
in here right interested to know
what your assessment is of the uk
economy
now and how well we are positioned to
embark on a green uh
building background well for the moment
of course as we know we're in the middle
of a gas crisis we almost had a fuel
crisis there'll be other crisis as well
because inflation is going up all across
the world commodity prices going up
staff shortages you were covering that
earlier of course in the economic
session you head
so all these things are extra precious
for firms now if you are to seriously
move into
greening your manufacturing or your
processes more generally or your
offering then you do need to spend some
money to be able to do that and can you
really
upscale whatever it is that you develop
as a pilot
and that requires
quite a lot of risk to be taken by firms
because you don't really know which
technology is going to work in the
future the government needs to
absolutely step in what can be done in
terms of education in terms of actions
in terms of accountability to flow
further through industry and down supply
chains to support smes that do want to
um proceed with this in future you know
we've got lots of plans about
decarbonizing the economy by 2050 or
2040 or something like that what can we
do tomorrow what can we do and i think
there are countless smes who are
coming up with all sorts of ideas and
solutions and we don't get a seat at the
table very often it's driven by big
business and there's a lot of money in
big business and it's critically
important i mean i think one of the
things i want to say is that we can't go
from you know where we are today to a
totally decarbonized economy overnight
it's not it's a transition we have to do
it in a transformational way but there
are there are
things that we can do now that will
start to drive down short-term emissions
and the thing that i would like to see
um
two things i think i'd like to see
subsidies removed from fossil fuels
because that provides a really
unbalanced
playing field we see um the global
economy is driven by
fossil fuels which are subsidised to the
tune i think the international monetary
fund last week said uh 11 million
dollars a minute
and so when you're saying when we're
saying that environmental products are
more expensive we're not competing
directly but if we were to get 11
million dollars a minute to support the
transition to green economy then we
wouldn't be expensive perhaps really to
what extent are pledges genuine to what
extent are they green washing who's even
keeping track it's very easy to talk
it's very easy to make promises and
pledges and say we're going to do these
wonderful things we know that it is
harder to do the next step and nobody's
going to say that that's easy but
definitely the steps need to be taken
and it's not enough to come up with a
great big you know plan and a promise
without actually having a delivery uh a
delivery plan behind that
and the commitments that have been made
in the exhortations that have been made
are insufficient and that is the the big
issue around cop26 that so many promises
are going to be made and it's going to
be glitzy and and glamorous and you know
on the tv all the time and people are
going to get credit for great big
announcements but actually there's a lot
of work that needs to be done behind
that i just want to come back to you on
that very question i mean your pledge to
cut emissions by 30 by 2030 who keeps
track of that
so we we follow a
science-based target system where it's
audited by accountants as you talk about
as well and i think the key thing for us
is some of our pledges are not as
far-reaching as other people in the
industry but we have had years of taking
action and delivering on our promises
and what that's taught us
is actually it's very important to make
far-reaching commitments so we think
that's important because it
it talks about the aspiration the
leadership behind it but it's how you
follow up on it so i think measurement
is really important commitment at
operational level
as well as at leadership level and then
being very clear on the programs that
drive improvement whether it's on farm
in factory or actually in the way that
we move products so actually for for us
we spend much more energy and how do we
bring things to life in reality
than the pledges
[Music]
now i don't know what the collective
term for a group of uh sky news
presenters is a sort of a launch of
presenters
perhaps but hopefully uh
no introduction required now my far left
ed conway our data and economics editor
samantha washington
my fellow presenter trevor phillips my
fellow presenter we're here really to
sort of chew over what we've picked up
over the course of the day one of the
big themes for me that's come out of
today and sam certainly when you were
talking to mark carney it came out in
spades which is the rising cost
of
the transition away from fossil fuels
that that pivot towards net zero the
cost is becoming ever clearer and i
wonder whether the authorities are
actually being honest with publics about
that around the world well i think
there's a lot of debate about to what
extent the government needs to be
subsidizing this to what extent
individuals are going to be responsible
but i thought one of the really
interesting things that came out of
talking to the former governor of the
bank of england um was the
the delta in the amount of investment
now going into uh on companies balance
sheets towards net zero goals so he was
talking about back in paris um
less than a third of countries that were
there had net zero commitments and after
that that's gone up now to three
quarters
of countries but cascading down from
governments getting involved as has been
corporates also uh getting involved in
in green recovery and investing in green
infrastructure and he said that that
corresponding number had gone from five
trillion invested on companies balance
sheets up to 90 trillion of course
there's still a lot of challenges
because 90 trillion is an awful lot of
money but we need hundreds of trillions
to invest in in green infrastructure
some of the sectors are already
profitable i think solar and wind and
you can see what's happened with the
electric car
industry as well you know that you have
the electric car companies that are
worth more than a lot of the other
top car companies combined all of us
have been to kind of conferences you
know perhaps like this one or others
where people have talked very boldly
about what they're going to do about net
zero or about kind of greenifying their
processes
but in the last kind of three or four
years it's just started to feel more
real hasn't it and that's kind of what
what mark carney was kind of talking
about that that has turned into real
money now extended to real commitments
but what's interesting like he's saying
is
the
the fact that it's very easy to make
bold promises it's very easy to you know
be a cop and make a promise about about
something that you haven't necessarily
got a kind of strict plan for like sam
was was was quizzing mark connie about
but when that becomes real and you
actually have to implement it and it
leads to higher inflation it leads to
higher energy costs
then things can get crunchy and and i
feel like we're kind of getting to that
crunchy stage now you know solar solar
is much cheaper now why is it cheaper
it's cheaper partly because we've got
better at making solar panels but it's
cheaper partly because
most of these solar panels are made in
china
and what is powering that process coal
and coal is very cheap and now suddenly
china is deciding you know whether it's
actually going to start using actually
be using as much coal as it was before
and suddenly
solar might not look quite so cheap in
the future so you know this is this is
where
it gets interesting i say you know in
italics because i think
the next few decades are going to be
more crunchy when it comes to uh to the
to the net zero debate
we've just gone through this period
where we've had cues at petrol stations
the talk is of inflation of stagflation
there's there's more than a sort of
whiff of the 1970s
about this as someone who's around in
the late 1970s i mean
i mean i was there too but i was only at
school i hated to add i mean
do you do you think the comparison is
going to get into far many knots
do you think these comparisons with the
late 70s are being overdone
uh i don't think they're being overdone
but i think they might be um
might mislead us
i think what we were seeing there was
the end of something
the disruption was we could see the end
of primary industries coal and so on
coming
um we didn't know what's coming next but
that was all about the end of something
and how
we managed that process today i think
what we're talking about is the
beginning of something and we just don't
quite know how that's going to work it
struck me in the the the fight the panel
that i was doing is thinking about it uh
simone rush
made it used a good example of a digital
company that's succeeding in lead and it
struck me
what we're talking about now is a
destruction to some extent of geography
now the north used to be the north
because of coal
and salt uh and iron and ports
now
in a world where those things have gone
frankly those industries gone somewhere
else and what we're doing now is what
hugh's talking about in leeds
the geography's destroyed
one of the things i'm just wondering is
if we've
slightly killed ourselves
the whole today that there is going to
be something separate called the north
that is basically all we've got time for
we are going to be back at some point
very soon with more big ideas live but
in the meantime thank you very much
indeed for company today
[Applause]
[Music]
you